Jerome Boateng auch für ihn heute in
ganz wichtiger Tag die Nummer 20 1 in
diesem Trikot hatte er uns zum
Fußballweltmeister gemacht ja
Deutschland war eben auch Boateng so
viele fußballkids wollten damals sein
Trikot ja und jetzt tja jetzt ist er im
Gerichtssaal heute das wird wohl sein
wichtigstes Urteil Frauenschläger Ja
oder Nein rufe immer beschädigt ja oder
nein
Weltmeister Stilikone Fußball Idol ein
Held für Kinder FC bayern-legende
Ballkünstler bei Olympic Lyon jetzt
spuckt der Blut ins Gesicht seiner Frau
Jerome Boateng Vorwurf Körperverletzung
am zweiten Tag im Berufungsprozess geht
es um alles der Kicker und jetzt auch
mutmaßliche Frauenschläger soll 2018
während eines Karibik Urlaubs seine Frau
und Mutter seiner Kinder ins Gesicht
geschlagen haben im Zeugenstand seine Ex
die massive Vorwürfe gegen den WM-Helden
erhebt Boateng habe ihr mit Wucht den
Daumen in ihr Auge gedrückt sie zu Boden
geschleudert und er habe sie mit der
Faust ins Gesicht geschlagen er hat mir
in die Niere geboxt Boateng habe sich an
ihrem Armband an seiner Lippe verletzt
er spuckte mir aus sein Blut ins Gesicht
Maulschelle Ohrfeige Geldstrafe 1,8
Millionen Euro soll der Champion zahlen
doch für den Millionär und
Fußball-Weltmeister ist das zu hoch der
Richter wollte ein schnelles Verfahrens
Ende um allen Beteiligten ein ungutes
Verfahren zu ersparen das Angebot des
Richters Boateng hätte die vorsätzliche
Körperverletzung und Beleidigung zugeben
müssen dann hätte das Gericht nur noch
über die Höhe der Strafe verhandelt das
Angebot des Richters lehnte der
Fußballer ab für Deutschlands Fußballer
des Jahres 2016 ist aber der Preis für
körpergewalt zu hoch
er kann das Angebot nicht mit seinem
Gewissen vereinbaren und vor seinen
Kindern verantworten jetzt geht es für
den Fußballstar um Alles oder nicht
vor Gericht erschien der Fußballer in
einem grauen Anzug und mit weinroter
Krawatte er wirkte sehr nervös sehr in
sich gekehrt jetzt soll es zum Urteil
kommen und laut Gericht könnte das für
Boateng durchaus härter ausfallen als in
erster Instanz
Jérome Boateng ehemaliger
Fußball-Weltmeister ehemalige Ikone
ehemaliges Idol jetzt Frauenschläger die
Schlammschlacht vor Gericht ein
Gesichtsverlust
heute also das Urteil dass man dann
natürlich auch live mit dabei und werden
das verkünden was dabei rauskommt
[Musik]